what's your biggest gym know know where
you're like you're not supposed to
[ __ ] do that in the gym I don't like
when people talk to me if I'm a little
work that's like dude wait till
someone's gonna drink that we have done
like yes what are you doing that
I remember at Gold's Gym that's put
signs around the gym say if you
recognize someone do not talk to them
it's like what the [ __ ] man especially
headphones I'm bill Bessette do you see
me sweating god damn it
my biggest gym no no there's two of them
one and this is always for whatever
reason an Asian dude with with jeans
work boots and a tank top
that'll bothered me jeans bother me geez
work boots and tank top but dude I'm
telling you I don't like when girls in
full makeup no I don't like that and I
don't like when you're talking on your
phone at the gym all phone on the gym
drives me nuts
photos gym singing at a gym with your
head singing oh I don't like loud
grunting or what about the dude dude
he's got a pound dumbbell but he feels
like he needs to drop it from I can't
[ __ ] rest out on the ground bro and
then obviously the big one everyone
knows is not racking your weights it's
like dude come on man yeah yes come on
but from nosin a Torcy known for that
forever was Romanowski bill Romanowski
he wouldn't rock and trans same gym and
he just leave all his [ __ ] out but I
heard he was like steve-o a giant
[ __ ] he was always nice to me but
yeah that's the guy I already was a
giant ass it'd be tough to do but which
at this time yeah hard to say something
to him at the gym because he probably
would hole in your chest and your music
you know how to track your weight yeah
you know what I'm gonna put all that
that's my workout I love the guy also
who's sure he knows exactly what he's
doing at the gym and he just walks
around and gives people take tips dude
you know what you want to do for that
bro you know you're new for your traps
bro you know you're doing you know
that's good they try bro that's good
yeah if you just arch your back here and
then get on your knees
telling you yeah the Vice can like yeah
why are you I don't remember asking for
advice and you're five for 370 like
that's not what am I gonna get your
shape yeah because that's not what I'm
that's not what I'm going for
I had a dude follow me
to the locker room I was trying to [ __ ]
so he said because I was at the stall
and I was in the urinal and he came
urinal next to me but he came here and
all next to me naked so and he starts
talking to me
and I'm like that's another gym no no
don't talk naked bro no no I don't tell
ya what we got it but that's usually
dudes over the age of 65 my dad put his
nuts in your face and talk to you we're
the photo dead serious conversation my
dad does that Captain Morgans Yeah right
in your grill yeah my dad way up there
right here's what I'm thinking for doing
my dad go conversation just a light
salad I'm thinking a light salad and
then some sort of protein I mean there's
not this big [ __ ] Pappas shop nuts
just hanging up I was like oh ah I'd
seen 90% of time I'll tell you sir Rob
right before he kills we show him just a
tad Brian I had the at the time at the
time the biggest meeting ever in our
lives network TV Fox had a Fox's meeting
with us right and they in to pitch we're
sound on my show he's already sold but
he wants to meet with Brian and Brennan
to go over the exact pitch of the idea
for the green light there's budget
there's everything this guy's the head
of Fox he's not there anymore had a fox
though they said be there tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. I know no problem
everyone leaves all I get Brian go bro I
don't asked a lot from me he goes well
you're always late I went tomorrow such
a big deal for us we'd have our own
national syndicated [ __ ] TV show dude
why everything we've ever dreamed up
please don't be late he goes dude late
never what time you show 9:30 get the
[ __ ] out 9:30
so what's everyone of self-sabotage of
self-sabotage yeah but he takes it you
should be his picture and dick thing
like this was way wait was was or
actually his fashion he was late to that
picture username yeah like this would be
a Twitter egg it's just like good dude
wait so who's waiting at that meeting
right there
so it's you it was your agents it was
just
mean Brian the agent sorry I met with
him do you want just meet with the
talent so me and Brian go in so I go in
by myself and I'm like oh I told Brian
to come a little late cuz I'll covered I
cover the business aspect and I wrote
this thing mainly myself socked over it
I tell him just come in so I mean you
and the guys like okay yeah like I run
across the street like a [ __ ] copy or
something at Whole Foods been between
shooting below the belt find the kid
well today I got here early to do this
podcast and I went to get coffee and I
was like you know what I've earned I
fast all day yesterday fast this morning
I had a nice healthy salad for lunch I
was like I have a sweet tooth on me a
coffee and some gingerbread cookies
because Whole Foods has my favorite
gingerbread cookies so I ran over there
and then I don't wait fresh the light
I've crossed the traffic where no lights
good like a dumbass cuz I'm trying to
get across and traffic is busy manage
sprinted and I almost got hit by this
truck Jesus crying I thought [ __ ]
oh these [ __ ] gingerbread cookies
will flying there and people they would
just like this make sense that this
makes sense he died oh no oh well this
speech I would have to know dude the
breeze oh you know did you know what can
I be honest I haven't I have nightmares
you don't know this but I actually have
recurring your you know you go like that
when you have thought he almost got
killed in front of me like before his
fight I'm not joking kill standing next
to his Porsche we were at Adam Corolla
ah and I and I still get I mean he went
Ceylon
how long ago first of all first of all
he been training and he's ready for the
fight of his life five years ago and and
and I was like Tia and Adam Carolla
promoting the podcast you go say it off
boom like like almost touched his face
and he went up and I went oh [ __ ] dude
oh and I still think about it I stood
there I should go Dan that's crazy
see you tomorrow what are you gonna do
yeah just dodge turbo it was a car
flying and I weird just [ __ ] I was
it pay attention I'll see ya not good
numbers like it's like my buddy hooked
up with this gal and he's a big boy and
she was she was he looked at her and
they had some pretty hot sack
and then he looked at her she was
standing there and she she was a stout
young lady she was he went outside
because she was giving it she was giving
him too what for you understand okay is
he's a big strong guy and she was kind
of giving it back like meeting him
halfway in the bedroom kind of tossing
him around I said well [ __ ] and he goes
and he's got a he's got a scale and he's
got what's one of the skills that
measures your height too
and he made her get on and he goes Bubba
stand on the scale for thought-bubble
she was she was a little drunk and she
goes okay oh wow he clocked her in at
five foot almost three five foot almost
3 1 8686 six pounds yup and he looked at
her fabric it was a lot of stuff and he
looked there he goes I can't glad the
nerve of hurt again let's guess she went
Wow and he goes and he was right man he
goes not good numbers probably not good
numbers and then he goes pretty boy but
impressive yeah he's use a little
bowling ball he hit me a little little
meatball yep call me and go see little
meatball call me and when I went 5/3 186
last night hold mine I know you did and
he goes yes I did and he measured her
man circular as well because who had
only other personas a scale to measure
people's height and weight like that a
psycho well he Dexter chin and now this
he's always he's always measuring
himself and by the way that's strange he
told me he told me he goes do I know
oh yeah how old is and he's 50 something
and and then he goes back in he went and
I'm hanging out with her and her pajamas
were hanging open
and I went back in for thirds so I was
like that's impressive enough for the
human meatball that's it
sometimes you know you know sometimes in
the devil works yeah sometimes the nice
mix it's spicy meatballs I have had I
have had wonderful experiences with with
strong stout men oh that's where you
were go where math yeah whenever I said
women little to analytics with dick no
say we're a plane being evacuated
because a woman had a you know one of
those pets that help you out with
anxiety and everything else yeah what's
it called again
I mean it's emotional suffer motional
super show support [ __ ] oh [ __ ] a
squirrel
why would people afraid of it it's
considered a rodent ro consider a rodent
so was the rodent flipping out no it was
in its own little carrying case we're
flipping out well she's kind of messed
up too because they said she can't bring
it on board she has to leave and that
she would refuse to leave so everyone
else had to do board the plane but so
she brought on board and the lady like
the fly to him I was like well ma'am can
I squirrel on the playa and it passed
TSA checkpoint because I guess they're
not the ones that have to stop you and
also TSA the worst like oh we get the
cat very cool carry on it's up to the my
question is why a dog and not a squirrel
squirrels get a bet well you know II
just had mini horses I've heard many
horses God but hilarious I don't know
dude I would be irate if some [ __ ]
brought her stupid squirrel on the plane
and wouldn't get out I mean you want to
see her yes misses her again
she uh
[Music]
that's not the good dude let the scroll
that [ __ ] cage him attack people's
face it this girls are feisty dude
squirrels actually you don't get the bad
rap is the lag is there any diamonds
getting the crown rot no these have a
fancy tail Don's there she is she's
flipping people off and she yelled that
before how much she was getting carried
out she's like I'm the crazy woman I'm
the crazy one and this shirt flipping
everyone off
however Jimmy Kimmel picked this up and
she was on a new station Fox 8 and look
oh he loves the [ __ ] squirrel
probably single layin older oh she's
buried with the daughter
okay okay Kimmel how good how
good-looking is now he's lost weight
yeah handsome son she pride she's just
uh older oh wow that's the you know he's
cute yeah okay see a sugar glider Oh
what is he a sugar glider squirrel big
difference no their lives are cute
you're like flying squirrel nuts yeah
they're cute
no those are big this is a real those
are actual squirrels are big uns you
know you ever seen a sugar glider now
you can buy sugar gliders I hid at the
pet store yeah yeah yeah they're tiny
yeah at friends who have different
animals little sugar gliders not [ __ ]
how to straight-up squirrel like from
your backyard yeah when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a chimp through 30 timespan while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift